what am i on i'm on i think this is
18. oh my god
all right my cone couldn't handle it
[Music]
anymore
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to co-heads on
first we feast the coolest
sweetest show on the internet you know
ice cream always brings back so much
nostalgia for me because i always think
back to my first banana splits
hot fudge sundae you know the classics
but here on coneheads we're all about
exploring
newer cooler sweeter territories and
these days i really
can't open my phone without seeing some
sort of ice cream hack on tick tock or
these giant 22 scoop creations that just
makes your mouth
water but do these hacks really
hack it do they deserve your efforts
to find out today i have a special guest
with me inga lam from buzzfeed and tasty
on her show she does all these viral
creations and tries out amazing hacks so
she can let us know whether something is
deserving of your time welcome to the
show inga
thank you mike thanks for having me i'm
very excited to be here
my first question to you is that there
are so many of these hacks and viral
creations out there
what makes it inga lamb worthy what do
you try
first wow england worthy i am not worthy
of having
that phrase attached to me but obviously
viral creations when we speak of it we
think of something that's very
like just attractive visually something
that you look at and you're like oh my
god i want to try it
but for me i think a good viral food is
something that both looks
and tastes really good now i do see a
lot of viral videos involving ice cream
what is it about
ice cream that makes things tend to go
viral even if it's not a viral creation
we love ice cream as it is
but to attach a viral component to ice
cream it's like
the cherry on top all right and go well
i've been craving ice cream all day you
ready to get started
let's go
all right so first thing we're going to
do is a diy cookie ice cream hack
and all you need is a two chocolate chip
cookies
ta-da and then your favorite pint of ice
cream
i mean whatever flavor i go for cookies
and cream you probably also have cookies
and cream and then you just need
a knife you call that a knife this is a
knife
[Music]
mike knows what's up i'm excited to cut
things what are we cutting here
first thing we're going to do is
actually cut the end
right here all right let's do it
now to cut off however much you want
this is
this is it
so what we're going to do is take a
cookie and just sandwich it
oh this looks like like i actually
molded it
it looks smooth and professional right
doesn't it look so
perfect it does look perfect it does
let's take a bite
sure zinga cheers
ah ah
is it good right i feel like i had to
unhinge my jaw a little bit for this one
but that was a good bite that was a good
bite
oh yeah all right sean inga do you give
this hack a thumbs up or down
you like it i think it's super smart
right i like it too it's so quick so
efficient like you said
did it even take 15 seconds probably not
challenges
if you're alone making this and creating
this hack there's no way you can just
like
let this go back into the fridge like
you would have to make a second ice
cream sandwich so
i don't know how you could stop i
couldn't stop i'd just be sitting here
making sandwiches all day
i definitely think this is a success as
well and it's a trick i'm going to be
using in the future so thank you so much
for that
what's next
[Music]
all right got a ton of stuff in front of
me very colorful we're making like a
ice cream rainbow or something pretty
much you're pretty close we're gonna
make a
cotton candy ice cream burrito
wow my inner child just exploded from
happiness
all right so what do we do base layer
our
tortilla if you will just try to make
like a relatively large pancake shape
this is a lot of sugar
i'm both happy and terrified at the same
time all right
so once you have your first layer done
just drizzle on your cereal
as much as you want i feel like this is
something that willy wonka would have
came up with right
i'm going to call my creation instant
diabetes
we are going to scoop on our ice cream
to make things easier for you you do
want to put it
in a single line next thing we're going
to do is put on
our frozen fruit i do want to say mom if
you're watching
i ate my fruit today
all the toppings are now on this is
the moment mike this is make it or break
it we are gonna wrap this
up you ready to do this i feel like my
heart is already beating so
fast it's gonna be beating even faster
after this goes into my stomach okay
let's do it
[Music]
holy crap i feel like one of those new
york deli guys that just made a sandwich
you ready for the big reveal let's do it
let's do it one
two three wait how come yours is bigger
than mine
because i like put a lot of cotton candy
in mine but your filling looks so good
look at it
hey not bad we made a burrito it's like
the devil smiling at you all right
so are we gonna eat this now we have to
take a bite
cheers to five years less of our lives
huh i could literally feel
multiple parts of my body decaying as
i'm chewing this
but but it's not bad you know it's bad
for you but it doesn't taste bad
am i right there's no way i can eat this
whole burrito could you how much of this
could you eat
um maybe like 1 20th
i will say even though the flavor is
very very sweet
i like all the textures that are going
on there's like the crunchy cereal
there's like the frozen fruit and then
the cotton candy the chewiness
and then obviously the ice cream the
creaminess so texture i'll give it full
points it's just like everything else
i don't know all right you ready for
final verdict
yes hands out thumbs out
verdicts
i don't usually give the thumbs down i
like to give everything a chance but
this really is just
it's too much sometimes there's a line
and this has crossed the line by
too far so thumbs down it is for me
all right angle we got to move on from
this this should not be around me
anymore you ready
yep time to put this down and move on to
our last thing
[Music]
all right anger come a long way together
now
there's one last thing i want to do i've
been seeing a lot of these huge amounts
of ice cream scoops stacked on top of a
cone and
i want to give it a shot so i want to
challenge you to an ice cream
scoop battle how many scoop of ice cream
can you fit
on top of a coal all right challenge
accepted ready to do this
also big shout out to lopez island
creamery that's where i got all my ice
cream today
where's yours from i got mine from
morgan stearns here in new york it's one
of our local ice cream shops and i'm
very very excited to be eating all this
today
all right and good so this is basically
the opposite of limbo instead of how low
can you go
this is how high can you go ready for
the first scoop
so ready let's do it what's your
strategy here
i'm trying to start with an ice cream
that doesn't melt as fast oh
she's on to what i'm doing i'm putting
the softer one on the bottom so it sinks
in more
scoop number two number two is on
scoop number three okay okay don't panic
so this is group number four five
number five let's go are you trying to
make it look pretty or just
viable of course i'm making it pretty
what about you
you are not making it pretty i don't
care as long as it stacks i just want to
win
that's your eighth yeah it's my eighth
all right i'm doing my ninth
oh your scoop is better than mine you
know what
that's an excuse true winners don't have
excuses
this is my 10th all right 10.
boom baby how's that
all right 10. my mine's leaning a little
bit i gotta
shift it a little bit so we both on 13.
mine looks like something created by dr
frankenstein
here mike take a look at this that
actually looks good
oh no no no
no oh my gosh no
yeah my strategy of putting soggy ice
cream on the bottom completely
negated the structural integrity of the
cone
i told you i'm gonna put one more
keep going see how many you can do how
you feel about that
15. 16.
i'm on i think this is 18.
oh my god all right
my cone couldn't handle it anymore oh
but but you caught it you know
that's a nice catch this is not
good oh my god all right well
i couldn't break the world record but
this looks good at least so i'm gonna
you know
try and take a bite how how
tastes like victory well yeah you bet it
does
all right guys even though i lost the
battle hey when ice cream is involved
nobody's ever a loser inga thank you so
much for joining me guys definitely
check out inga on tasty and buzzfeed
where you can watch it bring all these
viral food creations to life
thank you thank you for having me thank
you for letting me eat a lot of ice
cream i'm gonna be busy for the rest of
the day trying to finish this
giant scoop again thanks so much for
watching the coolest
sweetest show on the internet see you
next time congrats
you